Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new spider-man 3 daredevil video
recently several websites reporting that in
addition to Tobey maguire andrew garfield all
the spider-verse casting announcements the past
couple of weeks charlie cox is also supposed to
appear during the movie so we'll explain what's
going on what that means for the marvel netflix
characters in the future of the mcu if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing a giveaway for the spider-man
miles morales video game for playstation 5 or
playstation 4. all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you want
them to do with daredevil in the mcu now that
they have the rights to the character back there
been so many casting announcements the past week
about this movie everyone's just wondering who
else is going to show up now like pretty much
everybody you've ever heard of is going to have
a cameo during spider-man 3. but starting with
the big stuff number five earlier this year and
last year there had been rumors about daredevil
appearing in spider-man 3 in some fashion after
netflix canceled the marvel shows and marvel got
the rights back but if you didn't see any of the
save daredevil campaigns that had been running
all the hardcore fans were trying to get marvel
to do something with the character and not recast
charlie cox like we knew that they were gonna do
something with daredevil again because when they
canceled the marvel netflix shows they said the
daredevil will be back it's just that we didn't
know what they were going to do if they were
going to recast or they were going to completely
reboot the series but right after netflix canceled
the shows there was this contractual cooling off
period between marvel and netflix that specified
when marvel could actually use the netflix
characters again in new movies or new disney
plus series the deadline for marvel being allowed
to use the daredevil character specifically
again just ended this past week so they can
do whatever they want to with him this week
they just happen to be in the middle of shooting
spider-man 3 and they're making a bunch of other
casting announcements typically you only hear
them make casting announcements when they're
getting ready to need an actor to actually show up
in a scene that they're filming that's why a lot
of times you won't hear about really big actors
till right before they get ready to film with
them because they might not need them till the end
of filming remember the other day when the sony
channel accidentally posted a spider-verse
teaser video and then quickly deleted it
their account was also posting daredevil stuff the
other day too the cooling off period for the other
marvel netflix characters is still going on right
now so right now it's just the characters from the
daredevil series anybody that showed up during
that or debuted during that they can use again
but because of all this earlier this year of
course as you would expect charlie cox had been
asked point blake several times in interviews
what his thoughts were on all the daredevil
spider-man 3 rumors and keep in mind that this
was a couple months ago when he did this interview
this is what he had to say about that i
didn't i hadn't heard those rumors but
i mean it's certainly not my i'm
certainly not involved in any of
that i have not if that's true it's not with
me it's with another it's with another accent
i mean do you want to appear with
spider-man i mean it's spider-man right
look i just love you know look i'd love to i i'm
very grateful i had a great time i had a great run
of it i couldn't be happier i'm so grateful i got
to play that character for as long as i did but
of course you know of course i would love to keep
going and you know i'd love to be involved with as
much of you know i love it as a fan of the marvel
movies i love the little stuff that they do where
you kind of pop up here and there and that was the
one thing because we were on netflix we weren't
really able to do as much um i think for kind of
legal reasons i don't know why but i think that
was the reason. But i love the idea of you know
jessica and matt showing up in the background or
you know as a just as a lawyer advising peter
parker or whatever it is you know would be really
really cool so during that he claims he doesn't
know anything about it oh if they're talking about
daredevil showing up then it's not my version of
daredevil that seems like pretty boilerplate actor
language because behind the scenes if they start
saying oh yeah i'm definitely going to show up
usually that tanks their deal and they wind up
going in a different direction so they have to
pretend like they have no idea what's going on
no matter what's happening behind the scenes
the only reason why tom holland gets away with
stuff like that is because he is literally
the spider-man of the mcu around the time he
was doing this interview though was when we were
hearing rumors about all the spider-burst stuff
about andrew garfield and Tobey maguire showing up
and at the time sony and marvel just hadn't locked
any of those actors under contract yet so it was
still firmly in rumor territory but right now is
a completely different story because they started
filming the movie and it sounds like most of the
people have already been cast i just did a video
yesterday about alfred molina coming back as his
doctor octopus from the tobey mcguire spider-man
2 movie out of all the spider-man versions in
different spider-man franchises Tobey maguire
is supposedly the only one who still hasn't
signed a contract and apparently he was just
spotted at a new costume fitting for the movie
this morning just from the Tobey movies though
kirsten dunst has been confirmed to have some
sort of cameo during the film and obviously alfred
molina was just confirmed yesterday by a bunch
of news outlets so pretty safe bet if they're
coming back especially if kirsten dunst is coming
back then Tobey will sign his contract eventually
but just speaking about daredevil in the mcu and
daredevil spider-man crossovers if you're not a
big comic book reader daredevil used to cross over
with spider-man comics all the time daredevil is
even one of the other marvel characters that has
worn spider-man's costume on separate occasions to
help fool people into thinking that peter parker
was not spider-man like i can't be spider-man
because look there's spider-man in his real
costume swinging around fighting crime wouldn't
something like that come in handy if peter parker
and the mcu were trying to clear his name like
see mysterio was lying i can't be spider-man
because that's spider-man daredevil has also
been peter parker's lawyer as matt murdock before
they even did a version of that story during the
90s animated spider-man series this data will
clear parker and get it to your pal matt murdock
i'm sure he'll be grateful as i am for everything
hey we're even since you and i appear to be on the
same team i should tell you who our real adversary
is in all this his name is wilson fisk and just
for reference spider-man has also worn daredevil's
costume before too they have traded costumes
they're total bros in the comics it's just that
before now because sony and marvel weren't sharing
the character up to a couple years ago and netflix
had all those characters and they had such a weird
non-relationship with the marvel movies and it
kind of seemed like the movie directors didn't
want to have anything to do with the netflix
series that's why it's taken till now when kevin
feige controls all the marvel characters all
the marvel movies and all the marvel tv shows
so he has a much larger toy box of characters to
play with and he can pull them out and cross them
over however he wants to now because of course
daredevil being a new york city-based vigilante
should know who spider-man is and interact with
him every once in a while it's just that daredevil
is mostly local to hell's kitchen and spider-man
typically travels all over the city more depending
on what the adventure is just in terms of what
scenes daredevil might have or what they're doing
with him in the movie earlier this year when kevin
smith had set off a lot of speculation and rumors
most people theorized that daredevil would cameo
in the movie not as daredevil but as matt murdock
because until spider-man clears his name he's on
the wrong side of the law every single federal and
international law enforcement agency is after
him in addition to all the villains so if ever
there were a time for a good lawyer now would be
it calling up nelson murdoch and paige yes we do
have she-hulk coming into the mcu she's being
played by tatiana maslany i can't wait to see
what they do with that character she's a lawyer
too though and her disney plus series is supposed
to be released during 2022. so a lot of people had
wondered if she might show up during the movie for
something like that but i haven't seen any kind
of rumors about she-hulk since they announced
the casting i've only been seeing the daredevil
stuff but if he winds up showing up i'm only
expecting a very short scene there are already
so many characters they've announced people have
been posting memes about this since the doctor
octopus news yesterday Tobey maguire dr octopus
mary jane andrew garfield spider-man gwen stacy
electro michael keane's vulture character is even
supposed to come back according to his earlier
interview with jimmy kimmel so people are starting
to wonder if tom holland's spider-man is going to
appear in the movie himself oh he is just a small
cameo what kind of movie is this with all these
characters showing up so it's most likely that all
these other characters in spider-verse crossover
people will only be in the movie a little bit each
like cameo scenes at best and most of the movie is
still tom hall and spider-man figuring out how to
clear his name defeat new villains and making
himself a new costume of course he's probably
going to get a new costume during the film i know
everyone wants to see him become more like comic
book spiderman and start doing more stuff on his
own and one of the trademark things that he does
is create his own costumes so don't be surprised
if we see a much more advanced version of a true
homemade suit they did describe doctor strange
as being a main character but a main character
in the same way that iron man was a main character
in spider-man homecoming and iron man was really
only in that movie for about five minutes tops
just a couple key scenes but just in terms of
the future of daredevil inside the mcu after
this if he does wind up showing up in the movie
it's most likely that they would cross daredevil
over with the other street level heroes in the
disney plus series like moon knight she-hulk any
future daredevil series that they might want to do
on disney plus there's a big disney plus investor
meeting so we'll learn more about what's happening
with all the new disney plus series tomorrow
so whatever ends up happening of course i'll do
videos for that as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those videos
the only way spider-man 3 could get any crazier
though is that they announced an actor for
live-action miles morales or have some sort of
full-blown deadpool post-credit scene cameo and
just to be clear i do not think that deadpool
is going to show up anytime soon but post all
your daredevil mcu predictions in the comments
do you think he's going to show up in the movie
and what do you think they're going to do with
him in the mcu in the future congratulations
tristiano tricoche you're the giveaway winner
from my last big spider-man video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details everyone click here to learn
what's going on with dr octopus in spider-man 3
and click here for my new mandalorian season 2
episode 6 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!